hey guys how's it going matt here from
code tech tutorials nice to see you
around i just wanted to talk about a few
things mainly probably the title of this
video
visual studio seems to have a little
issue with not knowing how to
recursively search down through folders
when you search in your solution which
kind of took me by surprise
and also
made me realize
that pretty much anytime i stream on
twitch
it devolves into software gore because
i'm just constantly running into bugs
and glitches with every piece of
software i use it started out as me
trying to use streamlabs obs and just
change a few alerts to that like having
weird little download things locked on
the screen and things not saving and me
just being confused and people in twitch
chat yelling at me click done click save
there is there is no save already hit
done it didn't work it reverted back i
don't know why
so just want to make a quick little
little video about all that and i also
wanted to address that like i kind of
like lost my temper at visual studio i
had you know i've been streaming for a
while
and uh everything was going all right i
was uh
adding a stencil buffer thing to my
engine to be able to like outline
objects
and then i just got like hosed on this
uh recursive search thing and i kind of
like just
cursed at microsoft a lot for being
trolls
and that's not entirely true and i don't
think i was right you know all software
developers make mistakes
even if we're in big companies it still
happens
and it gets through qa it just happens
uh i should apologize to microsoft yeah
you need to fix your software that's
true but that doesn't excuse the way i
reacted especially live and this also
brings me to a few other things and it's
something i just want to be like
open about because it's a
it's a new year we're all moving forward
and i don't think i should try to tuck
this one under the rug
i probably have a little bit of anger
issues and it's kind of deep rooted you
don't see it usually i can control it if
i really need to but when i'm feeling
like uh you know i'm feeling a little
loose and and feeling good and feeling
like people are going to listen to me i
might just like start
start getting angry about something and
hoping that like someone will
agree with me i don't i don't know what
i want honestly i don't i don't know
what you know i'm going to try to do my
part i've got some habits that i want to
change i've been hitting the gym a
little more and uh
i'm kind of reworking my habits isn't
all about me but i just want to clear
this up because i know a lot of you guys
probably worry about me a little bit or
watch me and care so i don't know i just
feel a little obligated to say something
yeah there's a little more to it i don't
know how much i really want to get into
but i'm definitely reanalyzing my habits
and my lifestyle and trying to kind of
sort out what might be some underlying
problems with mood swings or something
like that may have lost my cool there
and that i it would have been a lot
better if i didn't and that was on
stream that time was definitely one of
the those instances so
it is what it is let's take a look at
visual studio now all right cool here we
are so i've got visual studio up just
loaded up my normal project it's just c
plus project but over here in this
solution explorer is really where the
issue shows itself so you have a search
your solution which tends to usually
work pretty good you don't have many
problems with this but i was as i was
doing these stencil buffers i wanted to
search very specifically for a few
things i was doing
and here in my code files and i've got a
lot of code files if you you know you
open these folders you see there's more
and more and some of them are
you know it's always being restructured
there's a lot of work being done here in
general so i just wanted to find uh let
me see if i can get the example here
okay i was just looking for like this
little set depth test i don't even see
this maybe a little small on the screen
i have this function called set depth
test so i have this whole
static front end for opengl that's just
my implementation of it to kind of
simplify it's not it's not that big of a
deal it's not really the point but
so set depth test it's called in several
places uh
in the code and i just wanted to see all
right where am i calling this so
naturally you would think okay let's
just search my solution for it and boom
it only finds it
in the file that
defines it literally the search will
only find the the string set depth test
and this
this graphics file the header and the
cbp but it's not the only place it's
used it's used all over the place i set
depth test in several different files
they just don't come up over here so i
was like why not that would be so great
and it's easy to do
you just recursively
search the plain text files
throughout the folders there's a there's
a linux command that can do it the first
one to put that linux command in the
comments when's the job at microsoft not
really but they do need you because i
don't think they've
got this one sorted out and you i'm sure
you can do it in windows 2 or with
whatever code they're writing visual
studio in these days so it's that simple
really
and that's the problem so yeah this
happened uh live i was going and i was
poking around i was trying to find stuff
and i got trolled by this ide and you
can replicate it yourself just write
some code use some code do a search
notice that it doesn't find it in all
the places pretty straightforward not
sure how you could miss this in a qa but
somehow they did so
that's pretty much
uh that bug what ide are you guys using
these days is there something better
than
visual studio community edition for us
coders that just want a good free editor
now of course i could just go to like
cmake and use whatever editor i wanted i
could use just notepad for all i really
care that'd be fine with me but you know
it's nice to have the features of an ide
to kind of help you along but however
when you have stuff like this where they
have a feature ready to go that sounds
great okay cool where am i changing the
depth test i need to know because i'm
writing a new piece of code and i want
to make sure it's arranged properly and
it just it won't show you
there should be several other files here
i'm pretty sure wherever i initialize
opengl i definitely call it which is
somewhere in the initialization of the
window here in interface
so there's probably a set depth test in
here yep there it is doesn't find this
one though that's no sign of it found
over here in the solution explorer
although yeah this is uh the graphics
files
no window file there but clearly it's
right here and it's like that throughout
the code for
anything in particular
so
yeah i don't i don't know what to do
someone suggested sublime text yeah okay
fine it's kind of a
i'm the sort of person who could adapt
to any sort of ide or editor uh i'm also
the sort of person who as i i kind of
mentioned earlier i find every little
glitch in every piece of software and it
drives me nuts which is mainly which is
one of the big reasons
why i became a software developer to
begin with because i was so tired of
this crap and i was just like i'm just
going to write my own because nobody
seems to be able to do it and it drives
me nuts as you can see i'm already
getting a little heated this happened on
stream too except i even got more heated
and i threw some through some guns at
microsoft which
in kind of in fairness in retrospect
maybe they deserved it but
uh or deserve it for something
this simple and uh easily
implemented it's not that hard to put in
a recursive search
but
i mean they have it partially
implemented i don't know what they got
wrong about it like
clearly it finds it in
the files where it's implemented but not
where it's used should just show them
all and you might think oh you don't
have your settings right no no i've got
it i've got it it's it's checked search
within file contents
and i can search within external items
too i did try that although that's not
relevant because it's not in an external
item but now it's uh it just doesn't
work i know what you're thinking
you're not using the new visual studio
2022 and uh don't worry i tried it there
too
same results it still doesn't find where
it is in my code so apparently they
haven't fixed this yeah still not fixed
even in the latest version i don't know
if they intend to fix something like
this it seems like a no-brainer that if
you have a search within your file
contents for a string that it should
find it in all your files but it just
doesn't and i could do that with any of
these functions
and it would produce the same results
so that's kind of annoying but yeah it
should be finding it in this file for
sure that's just one example
right there so why doesn't it why does
it only find it where it's defined and
not where it's being used i don't know
but even in the latest version of visual
studio we still
see the same issue all right so yeah
that's pretty much the video just wanted
to throw that out there and yeah if you
want to see me live stream i'm streaming
guaranteed on every sunday and every
wednesday now so twice a week
over on that uh site and i'm gonna try
to keep it nice and steady this year and
i'll probably stream a little bit here
and there just kind of when i feel like
it or when i can on the other days but
i'm not going to guarantee those ones so
i've even got a schedule up there anyway
that's it
peace out you guys